mr. Trump also toured an energy plant
and said farmers will prosper when he's
done negotiating trade deals we're
reversing decades of failed trade
policies opening up new markets and
fighting to give our farmers the fair
and level playing field they deserve
within a year and a half I would say
you'll be in the best position that
you've been in in 15 years many US
farmers are seeing their livelihoods
hurt right now because of trade disputes
with countries like China and recent
record rainfalls
Jean Reynolds is at a farm in Manhattan
Illinois that's near Chicago dean good
morning to you and the question now is
how badly are some of these farmers
doing well they're having a hard time
Gale good morning if you just look
around here this is the middle of June
and this should be a sea of green behind
me instead it's a field of dirt and
that's a condition that farmers across
the Midwest are confronting as the
calendar moves into what could be their
summer of discontent 12 bingo meet Dave
Castel yesterday we watched as he
planted the last of his corn crop on the
1,000 acres he farmed and just started
planning his soybeans both about six
weeks delayed from his target date his
farm like so many others had been
waterlogged by record rainfall we fought
rain and mother nature all the time and
mother nature's the boss last month the
US suffered its second rainiest month on
record much of it occurring in
Midwestern states like Illinois and Iowa
all at the height of planting season
that rain he's basically dead already
and subsequent hardening of the soil on
sunny days has stunted his corn crop you
need almost perfect conditions now to
make a go we need picture perfect
conditions to even get 2/3 of a yield
and what do you think the odds of having
a perfect balance between Sun and rain
let's just go to Vegas instead I think
your odds are better here the rough
weather an ongoing trade war with China
moved the Trump administration last
month to offer farmers 16 billion
dollars to help them
and help him retain their allegiance in
2020 like most farmers Castille does not
welcome tariffs but believes they are
away the president is applying leverage
to make trade more fair do you sometimes
feel like a pawn in the chess game here
that's being played yes and no I believe
in President Trump he's he seems harsh
right now but he's a businessman and
he's trying to make this fair trade
that's all he's trying to do is make it
fair
now all Dave Kissel has right now are
these tiny little plants just barely
poking their heads through the ground
they're supposed to be knee-high by now
but it's going to take several more
weeks for them to get there if they ever
do Tony all right Dean thank you very
much